and like i think that's the reality that
kind of hit me as like oh this i'm on my
own now and now i feel like
i'm finally like i'm actually on my own
shawn mendes is speaking out about his
personal struggles following his split
from camila cabello last year she's been
one of my best friends since i was like
15 years old opening his heart to social
media over the weekend the wonder singer
gets real about adjusting to the single
life and how it's inspiring a new song
a lot of the thing that also like is
resonating in the lyric for me is like
oh
you don't realize
like when you're like breaking up with
someone you like think it's the right
thing you don't realize
that comes after it like which is like
who do i call when i'm like in a panic
attack who do i call and i'm like
sean and camilla announced they were
going their separate ways in november
following over two years of dating
months later he says his new normal
hasn't been easy like i think that's the
reality that kind of hit me was like oh
this i'm on my own now and now i feel
like
finally like i'm actually on my own and
i hate that you know
that's my reality you know
this heartfelt message comes mere weeks
after the release of camilla's latest a
collab with ed sheeran called
[Music]
all
bombbomb
so fast
while it's yet to be confirmed by the
singer herself fans are speculating she
was likewise inspired by the couple's
breakup and here is just a few of the
lyrical clues
you said they the ocean but you're
surfing now
that's how the song starts and well we
know sean admitted this in late 2020. my
biggest fear is deep water and here's
another one i said i love you for life
but i just sold the house
it turns out the havana singer did just
sell her los angeles home in december
thankfully the singers have proved to be
friendly exes
in january sean shared a snippet of his
breakup ballad it'll be okay to
instagram
[Music]
he asked in the caption y'all dig this
and camilla jumped in the comments
writing quote you're crazy wildcat of
course these friendship vibes are no
surprise
he's the best and i think we're really
supportive of each other a source told
et at the time of their split that their
parting of ways was quote mutual
explaining quote they realized they are
in totally different places in their
lives at this point and it was time to
end things they're both sad about the
split but doing their best to take care
of themselves stay busy and surround
themselves by loved ones
[Music]